c'est le 3 janvier donc on a un oeil au
bon soin encore à prendre des bonnes
résolutions déjà on va donner de
l'argent à leur panache oui et j'ai aidé
bouche les mouches on voit là les des
bouchons parce que toi ça rejoint tout
ce qu'on vient de se dire tu veux qu'on
avait les bouchons le bug ça doit partir
le lot acheté provient explique les
bouchons c'est que en fait on demande 4
e cat moi je demande des bouchons on
demande en fait un acte d'amour fait par
chacun et tout au long de l'année
on se débarrasse pas avec un chèque dans
l'année on faisait tout au long de
l'année on ne demande pas d'argent et ça
finit par par faire de l'argent parce
qu'on recycle du plastique donc et c'est
jeudi lorsque j'ai un mec de gauche là à
droite aux bordaises que moi par exemple
je privilégie s'ils étaient les
religions les parties est au bas moyen
dirais non mais je veux pas être de l'un
ou de l'autre à klang j'aime des gens j
à des gens de gauche que j'aime bien les
gens de droite que j'aime bien et par
exemple qu'un jean françois copé sait
pas si c'est ton copain et ben les deux
mots le monde est par exemple un mot je
voulais saluer mots vraiment pour ça on
leur dire qu'ils sont recordman de
france de collecte de bouchons
parce que justement la mairie a fait un
local gauche tous les écueils de droite
et tous les écoles et toutes les écoles
réunies ces trucs qui réunissent dans
tout le département
c'est le département du koung khi
collecte le plus de bouchons et j'ai
envie de dire à tous les hommes
politiques de faire la même chose elle
tous les maires de gauche ou de droite
si jamais il mettait les locaux tu
parles c'est parce qu'on fait mais est
ce que c'est parce qu'au bal de bouche
en bouche non tout le monde passe comme
ça parce que tu as vu un truc dans un
coin tu le connais fauchant produits et
j'ai pas vu un truc dans un coin mon
petit bonheur j'ai pas vu un et j'ai pas
vu un truc
j'ai fait j'ai fait j'ai fait une
association qui ne demande pas d'argent
et fiches ce soit et qui ramassent 250
mes balles galets d'acheter des
fauteuils et pas que les différences et
lina ben mhenni pas chez tout joue bien
je demande à tous les hommes politiques
de tous bords et à tous les maires de
tous bords de mer attendue pour les
verts non ils n'ont pas attendu à temps
c'est moi qui m'en occupe au niveau du
management
on est cinq quand on est cinq au bureau
quand ceux qui l'ont trahi son et mario
fond de la poche équipe et à l'olympia
le manioc et de celle qui collecte les
bouchons et je dis que si on avait un
coup de main de tout le monde
je pense que ça serait bien et que si on
récolte on rigole très peut-être six ou
dix ou vingt fois plus de plastique et
avec une infime partie de nos poubelles
on peut non seulement faire un
orphelinat madagascar empêche les
tétines tous les camps et que ça se fait
sans demander d'argent et comme par
hasard les plus exemplaires de tous les
citoyens pour moi sont justement les
enfants parce que les enfants qui ne
sont pas dans le monde de l'argent ont
compris que si je t'ai pas le bouchon
dans la poubelle c'est eux qui disent
papa ou maman jette pas le bouchon
ça peut acheter un fauteuil et ben voilà
par exemple un exemple global qui n'est
acquis et sans parti pris pour qui que
ce soit et qui est juste un exemple
d'amour
ok
pour qu'on comprenne ma réaction
il faut qu'ils la comprennent il va
passer jamais le bras c'est un truc de
gens du midi ça tu connais pas bien sûr
qu'est ce que je touche à j'ai bien une
petite idée
alors non mais je les ferai ma réaction
parce que il fait un truc bien moi je
trouve ça magnifique la pêche et tout
mais il faut arrêter de mettre dans tous
les discours et nanani nanana les
politiques comme si on nous montre du
doigt sans arrêt qu'elle aide à des gens
écoutent pas ce que j'ai dit yann écoute
moi j'ai des gens tous les sénégalais ce
que je veux dire c'était possible dont
tu parle à quelqu'un dans mon
département on a décidé ça qu'on
mettrait en 2000 euros par tête de pipe
dans les actions de solidarité au niveau
du département et je veux pas c'est pas
pour me vanter moi si je mens pas mal au
département c'est l'essonne c'est
conseil général et évaluer les indiennes
des 1000 m2 le corps était plein
d'espoir et donc non mais cela je veux
dire il ya des tas de gens qui font des
choses pour faut pas toujours montrée du
doigt un autre comme si les gens qui
s'est engagé en politique parce qu'ils
sont engagés aux politiques du bien sûr
que toujours suspect tout le temps non
ça fait un bond à la fin et ben juge
mais ouais c'est pas comme ça tous mes
tatouages justement pas c'est justement
parce que désormais je pense que je
perdais look des dirigeants jean-luc dit
docteur bordel et ça se voit pas citant
un bond à chaussures bottes un peu
couillon des fois avait avait fait un
bond sont ben oui je compte du coeur